what are some advantages and
disadvantages of having a publisher wow
okay comic book
publishers uh I don't want to say this
categorically but I will they're in
business to get movie and TV
deals you could make some money
publishing a book but the real money is
in doing deals for film and TV it's in C
calculable different and also licensing
very important so film TV
licensing is where the real money
comes
and uh so for
example
uh Ken lvin who founded first Comics my
my personal
publisher uh you know back in the
day uh
uh Ken founded first Comics as what's
called a creator-owned
company what this means is as follows
Marvel and
DC own all their characters they own
Spider-Man right they own Superman
Batman Captain Marvel Etc so when you
when you work for when you get published
the only way you get published through
Marvel or DC is if you're writing or
drawing stories based on their
characters and it's a work for hire you
know they pay you x amount you draw you
write um Creator own books like the ones
that first comics and some other
companies publish they're still those
characters that you create like Zen is
still owned by Dan and I right uh
but what Ken as a publisher can do and
what Harry Marcos my UK publisher of
marosia can do and it's incorporated
into the publishing contract is they can
take your property and sell it as a
movie as a TV show for example right and
those
deals are what's really lucrative so so
for example when I with the director
friend wrote the latest incarnation of
the Zen live action movie script that
goes into Ken's hands cuz he's like the
facto he's my manager as well that's
part and parcel of the deal for these
kind of
scenarios so uh it can be very important
to have a
publisher uh lots of people just try to
self-publish which is fine like they'll
put their books up on Amazon and sell it
both as a hard copy and digitally like
you know read it on the Kindle right
um but you know when you're in that
position uh you have to determine what
are you trying to do are you just trying
to sell some books do you want to get a
movie deal you want to get a TV deal you
want to get licensing you know this is
this is the maze you go through when
Hollywood gets involved right
so it's very advantageous to me like and
to some of my clients for example I did
a book a horror story for a client who's
like a writer and a director named
Philip Landa okay and the book which
marosia published is called
Shepherd and based on that book uh Phil
got a movie deal and it was shot the
movie you can see it wherever it's
posted
on um it's called shepher right but that
came about primarily as a result of
there being uh a graphic novel right
we've also done books for
example uh uh the uh Mark Roberts he
created the TV show uh Mike and Molly I
think mallissa McCarthy that was her big
starring vehicle and before that he was
uh one of the head writers if not the
head writer for years on one of my
favorite sitcoms 2 and a Half
Men so we
adopted a a stage play that he wrote
called rant tool and die r a n t o u l
that's the name of a town ran tool and
die which is this
incredible black comedy dark comedy
right and we adapted the the stage play
into a graphic novel right but but you
know Mark has his own uh agents you know
like maybe it's CAA or William Mars I
don't really know where okay so so he
can move his products through
his connections so whether you uh
self-publish in which case you're out
there fending by yourself against the
world or you can get a publisher like uh
first comic or marosia or some of the
others like image is a big one and uh
Dark Horse okay uh so if you get a a an
established publisher they can take your
and will take your product and attempt
to sell it in these other media okay um
so these are the various ways one one
can go do you think so many young
creators though they see all this IP te
out there but they they don't realize
that the initial character the initial
story has to be special it has to be
something that audiences will resonate
with that they just want to rush to the
video game the movie the products yeah
and that'll get you nowhere fast right I
mean uh I'm sure there are the rare
occasions where somebody comes up with
an idea and they Rush putting it
together and it turns into a success I'm
unaware of that
but they probably exist but probably in
small number right um uh you know
there's no I think the key in wanting to
produce your own comic or graphic novel
you have to have the passion for it like
I've been obsessed with Comics since I
was a kid I don't even know why it just
happened right uh so if you're obsessed
with comics and graphic novels and you
have a story you want to to tell you'll
get it done one way or another you'll
find an artist or you'll find
me um and you'll uh one way or another
get it published whether it's
self-published or you'll pitch it to a
publisher uh there's no there's no uh on
set blueprint or pathway as to how to
make this happen how much does it cost
to typically produce an independent
comic well here's what I can tell
you Marvel and DC the two big comic book
companies when they
pay their creative team on any book
which is
writer
pencil
inker colorist letterer the five
essential people those two companies
which are admittedly giant companies
they pay the going rate of $500 a page
okay to pay those five people that's
what it costs okay so the average a
20page book you do the math it's 20 time
500 I think that's
$110,000 that's what it costs them to
produce a 20page
book um again as I mentioned earlier
because I use super super talented
people but people who don't
necessarily reside in the
US I pay them like I my total combined
page rate is a
fraction of that but I can tell you this
there's a one artist an alumni if you
will of a storyboard is an artist who
lives in Mexico his name is Enid
balam uh he did
a beautiful major project for us and he
is now a top artist at
Marvel they saw his
work and he's working on some high
profile titles for them like there's one
coming out called spider Gwen which is
probably Gwen Stacy was a girlfriend is
of Peter Parker who's now got spider
powers right and and there's talk of a
movie with some big actress going to be
but but Enid who cut his teeth on
storyboard as well as I guess other
projects he's doing that book that's
great he also does like New Mutants
which is an X-Man kind of spin offer in
that wheelhouse right so so I guarantee
you what he's making now from Marvel is
like three to five times what I paid him
but when at the time you know he was he
you know I can't bend somebody's arm to
sign a contract with me so he was very
happy and uh the exchange rate was good
with Mexico but but we have had artists
who have now uh moved up you know and
he's not the only one yeah what advice
would you give to someone who's looking
to get a comic book
published the advice would be
this go to a comic book convention of
which there are many I I believe
currently every weekend somewhere in the
United States There's a comic book
convention the biggest one is of course
ComicCon in San Diego where they're
pushing at 200,000 people who attend uh
I call ComiCon in San Diego the five-day
endurance test I always need a week
afterwards to recover when I get back
right um but whether you go to Comic Con
or last week I was at La Comic Con but
they're in Florida new New York ComiCon
everywhere everywhere everywhere so
go approach Publishers with your
portfolio if you're a
writer give them a print out or
something you've written if you're an
artist show them your art
portfolio the best way to see if you
might have what it takes or somebody
Sparks to your talent is to go to What's
called portfolio review that they have
at almost every comic book
convention and you'll and and these
people are
unsparing if they think your work is not
that good they'll tell you why it's not
that good constructive criticism not you
know just for the sake of being critical
right but there's no better way to judge
and to find
out where your work stands than to show
it to professionals who are sitting
behind those booths or at that uh
portfolio review table that's the way to
do
it